es ist vollbracht diesen läuft sapinas
wohl vor einigen stunden ausgestoßen
tesla hat endlich sein produktionsziel
erreicht es war ein langer weg und hat
auch allen masc an seine grenzen
gebracht will elektromobilität ist es
ein riesiger schritt e-autos werden so
zum massenprodukt mit welchen
ungewöhnlichen maßnahmen er dieses ziel
erreicht hat jetzt bei klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen bei
denen mars chroniken heute übrigens aus
meinem gästezimmer am cern in genf
[Musik]
es war ein langer und ziemlich steiniger
weg schon vor monaten wollte maske ist
geschafft haben 5000 models in der woche
zu fertigen doch monatelang mit der er
diesen ziel hinterher und zum schluss
wurde sogar ein saboteur entdeckt der
wohl für brände in der produktion des
models wie verantwortlich war
es war eine harte zeit für macht er
selbst hatte es produktionszelle genannt
ihnen musk musste sogar in der tesla
verbringt übernachten um die probleme in
der produktion zu lösen dabei hatte
alles so gut angefangen was kaufte sogar
2016 mit der eifeler firma grohmann
einen deutschen maschinenbauer der
produktionsanlagen für die
autoherstellung fertigte der erfüllte in
der folge dann sogar die verträge mit
den deutschen autobauern nicht mehr wohl
um sich ganz auf die fertigung des model
free zu konzentrieren nur so glaubte man
die ehrgeizigen ziele zu erreichen 5000
autos pro woche eine zahl die bei der
fertigung von massenmodellen als minimum
angesehen wird nur so kann kostengünstig
und effizient gefertigt werden doch nach
dem start der produktion wollte das
einfach nicht gelingen monatelang winkte
er hinter den hochgesteckten zielen
hinterher im märz waren es 2500 in der
woche dann im mai 3500 immer ein wenig
mehr aber die 5000 wollten einfach nicht
gelingen und das schien auch an mass
nerven zu zerren
er meldete am ersten april die pleite
von tesla beantwortete fragen von
journalisten einfach nicht und warf
ihnen dummheit vor und beschimpfte
generell die medien sogar ein portal zur
überprüfung der glaubwürdigkeit von
medien will ergründen naja zuletzt griff
macht zu einigen drastischen maßnahmen
errichtete kurzerhand eine zweite
produktionsstraße 1
allerdings fehlt neben zwei dinge dafür
die maschinen und eine produktionshalle
die maschinen lese einfach von roman aus
deutschland einfliegen ein teurer spaß
und als produktionshalle ließ er ein
riesiges zelt größe zwei fußballfelder
aufbauen bevor diese die arbeiter schon
in zwölf stunden schichten arbeiten
damit hat er sein produktionsziel jetzt
zum ersten mal erreicht und zwar auf den
punkt genau seine letzte ankündigung
lautete nämlich das produktionsziel wird
ende juni 2000
18 erreicht du hast der belegschaft ist
zu hören dass es zumindest nicht
dauerhaft gehalten werden kann zwölf
stunden schichten sind einfach nicht
dauerhaft mit einer hohen
fertigungsqualität zu halten es bleibt
also noch einiges zu tun für die
elektromobilität ist es allerdings ein
riesenfortschritt damit wird in den usa
zum ersten mal ein elektroauto für den
massenmarkt gebaut und das bedeutet auch
weitere fortschritte für die technologie
bei den jüngst vorgestellten nächsten
tesla fahrzeugen kommt offenbar eine
neue effizientere batterie technologie
zum einsatz das autonome fahren würde
immer weiter entwickelt und es werden
auch davon wenn wir ja immer mehr
erfahrungen in der praxis gemacht
batterie brände unfälle
all das was bei neuen produkten passiert
es ist also auch für die
elektromobilität einen riesenschritt man
sehen welche veränderungen er bringt
wenn er keine videos dazu und zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
hättet mich bei whatsapp darum geht ihr
die kaputte aber box hier auf youtube
und verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten
video täglich und garantiert einfach
hier draufklicken und am besten auch
meinen schwesterkanal blick zum social
media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste
aus der social media welt dafür hier
klicken aber nicht die genau glocke
vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit
der haut drauf klicken elon musk geheime
batterie revolution bei tesla bis dann
bleibt dran